Hi! My name is Chris Gagné, and I'm an Agile coach.
Today, I will talk about chickens and pigs.
Like chickens and pigs?
What's it got to do with Agile?
Well, here's the story:
A Pig and a Chicken are
walking down the road
The Chicken says,
"Hey Pig, I was thinking
we should open a restaurant."
Pig replies,
"Hmm. Maybe. What would we call it?"
And the Chicken responds,
"How about Ham and Eggs?"
The Pig thinks for a moment and says,
"No thanks. I'd be committed,
but you'd only be involved."
So it's a story about how committed
someone is to the cause.
The ham requires the pig sacrifice
while the chickens' eggs are easy to produce.
Traditionally the development team were the pigs.
While everyone else including:
product owners, scrum masters, customers,
and other stakeholders were chickens.
The idea was that pigs got the priority
for talking during team meetings
Sometimes chickens were even expected
to remain silent unless invited to speak
because they weren't the ones
who had their bacon on the line.
Ken Schwaber, co-creator of Scrum,
used to tell the story about chickens and pigs
and it was even part of The Scrum Guide
However, Ken and its co-creator Jeff Sutherland
removed it from The Scrum Guide in 2011
because it got a little too derogatory in practice.
Developers might say something like
The stakeholder can't talk to us during daily stand-up. They're just a chicken.
It's true. We do want the development team to be able to focus on their meetings without getting derailed.
But calling our leadership pea-brain birds
isn't going to win us any favors.
Since it hasn't been part of
The Scrum Guide in quite a while,
you may hear the term less and less often.
That's perfectly okay.
And it's still fine to use the term in your organization.
Just don't use it as a chance to
beat up on your stakeholders
If you really think about it...
We've all got our bacon on the line.
Best of luck! Oink Oink